upwards of 30 years Carnegie Mellon has
engaged in the state of the art research
on how students learn what psychological
processes are by which teaching actually
is effective and by which it's not we've
learned a lot over the last 30 years and
what we're doing now is pivoting from
just doing research on that too now
trying to apply the research to build
infrastructure both human wise and
technology wise so that we can take
advantage of that research and improve
student learning outcomes there's 30 or
40 courses we've developed in the oli
platform based on this approach there's
other smaller modules that we've
developed all over the map some of those
are in engineering some of them are in
language learning some of those are in
statistics some of those are in
philosophy courses and there's a big
area that we're working on in writing
there's all sorts of approaches they've
used and what we're trying to do now is
make that suite of tools that helps
teach writing available to all the
professors in the university so anybody
who's teaching any subject they have to
have some part of the courts involved
how to communicate either how to write a
paper how to make a pitch to a science
body that's going to give you a grant or
not how to give a business pitch if
you're going to try to sell a an idea to
venture capitalists how to say here's a
really complicated technical idea but I
have to present it to the layperson so
every course the professor gives the the
assignments out and they typically grade
the material by themselves and sometimes
they enlist the help of the experts most
of the time they don't but what we're
trying to create is a system by which
anybody in any course can offload or get
help from the people who have actually
developed the writing instruction tools
and develop the expertise so that they
can use the best techniques for teaching
writing in their courses without much
effort so we're creating a one-stop shop
that's going to allow professors from
any discipline to come in learn what's
available pick the things that are
actually helpful to their course and
then get help implementing their course
get help collecting the data help
analyzing the data
and improving the system as it goes
forward I think all of us are very
excited about that project because it's
something that could really affect
everybody in the whole University we
need resources to help us build the
infrastructure so that it's easy to use
for a much much wider community I mean
we've had a lot of projects that have
been funded by various foundations or
various government agencies and they've
all hired a staff of experts and
programmers and technical people who've
become expert at using and developing
these tools but if we want to bring this
out to the bigger world right we need to
make these things easy to use that takes
user interface design that takes testing
that takes project management that takes
technical development we have in mind
creating a system that's going to
actually implement this great learning
science and this approach in learning
engineering that we've developed and
make it available in a seriously easy
way for a much much wider audience for
us to do that we need help building the
infrastructure so that it's reliable
secure easy to use and continuing to
develop and improve in response to the
needs of the various institutions and
constituencies that we would like to see
use it